[Music]
i had a tendency when i would show up at
work to uh sing
i i always been saying i'm uh that's the
way i was that's kind of hairpin i am
so uh i used to walk into a set of
chairs often and say
oh the good life
and everybody kind of get a giggle and
say oh that kelsey he's irrepressible
but uh sam simon used to be on the
writing staff and cheers
he went off and became extraordinarily
famous as one of the creators of the
simpsons
sam gives me a call and says we caught
with his character uh he's been in the
show already but he doesn't speak
now he's going to speak we're going to
find out who is he's and we think you
should voice him
are you still singing it's who i am
so about a year and a half later i hear
that
you know the show has been on and it was
pretty well received
and then a buddy of mine who was a
professor at evanston illinois
sends me a picture and he says
can you believe this it was the side of
a building
painted with a giant mural of
sideshow bob with the words underneath
saying
free scishow
i am so thrilled to have right here on
my latest episode of just getting
started a gentleman who i've been a big
fan of and i haven't spoken to in a few
years when he appeared kind enough
on my daily rich eisen show his new film
or his films the space in between which
had some theatrical run back in april is
in a video on demand near you on june
15th and the god committee is coming to
theaters on july the second just
one of the many projects in the world of
kelsey grammer here i'm just getting
started how are you kelsey
good rachel good to see you man how are
you i am better for
chatting with you it is great to see you
god bless you
it's great to see you and uh you know
this this pod um that i i started just a
few months ago
when we were really thick in the throes
of covet 19 and
thick in the throes of when we might
just uh get back to reality and helping
people maybe
get started with their lives their
careers their
stories um because uh everybody has an
origin story and i'm curious about yours
how you just got started
kelsey oh origin story well okay it's
pretty good story uh
i was uh you know i was the
grandson of a guy that was kind of an
oil executive who
who raised me my my dad kind of
disappeared pretty early on
and uh as uh i grew through
my childhood i was kind of i was going
to be a navy man uh my friend had been a
military guy i
wanted to be in go to the academy go to
annapolis and stuff and then
gordon he died when i was 12.
and uh that kind of just short-circuited
the whole plan and then i suddenly ended
up
really involved in literature
shakespeare
some of the great novels and uh i
started thinking well i don't know if
i'm a military guy i'm thinking maybe
i'm something else
and um somewhere in around seventh grade
a new guy came to school to teach and he
was uh
a choir director and he said i want you
to come into my office tomorrow and uh
audition that's every boy in the school
and we all went and so about a you know
cut to a year later we're all he's got
these five or six different groups i
ended up being part of a group called
the singing
pines um we wore
sort of tuxedos and and the girls were
sort of formal dresses and we all sang
we went to different clubs around the
fort lauderdale area and sang for for
the bridge club or for
whatever event and a couple years after
that a fellow came to school and said
i'd like you to do a play for me so i
did a play
and uh at that time i thought
this acting thing's pretty cool maybe
i'll try this
so that was about my junior year and
i've auditioned i heard juilliard was a
good school audition for another couple
around the country and uh i got accepted
juilliard
and i thought well i just better go
there
so that that's a a good start right
there but
why did what were you wanting to be when
you went to juilliard who was there was
there anybody that we we would know of
that
question was there robin williams was
there we were we were pretty
tight um you know fell apart you know as
as different levels of success hit
different groups at different times you
know uh
christopher reed was there chris was
like the first of the bunch to kind of
really take off
uh i remember i was talking on phone to
uh kristen griffith was her name
a fantastic young actress at the time i
haven't heard from her in a long time
either but
she was great and we were just talking
on the phone and she said guess what
chris is going to be superman what's
holy smokes uh that was just the
greatest
greatest thing and you know you can go
out this kind of a career
a couple of ways you can be negative
about it
you can be negative about other people
you can be upset when
other people have good good luck or
whatever a good fortune but i always
figured that
if the people close to you are the
recipients of good fortune your turn is
on its way
and um that next was robin williams
robin took off and
got you know mork and mindy and i mean
all that stuff started happening and
then uh
another few years down the road i went
and did some shakespeare
uh things that i really loved doing in
san diego
went back to new york after that and a
year or so into that
yeah so i get a phone call and say you
want to audition for the television show
and you know i was cheers
and that was cheers so okay so before we
get into that
to that phone call and what it led to um
you know when people think of juilliard
they do think of shakespeare they don't
think of superman or
mork and mindy or frasier crane you know
right
so so how did were you thinking that
though were you were
did you have to adjust your sites or
anything like that based on
i was actually thinking about then this
is good this is a very good question
um i was thinking just theater
and mostly shakespeare classical theater
that's that's what i really fell in love
with i mean
the greatest writer of all time and uh
we're fools to you know forget that i
know there's a little bit of a movement
to kind of stop teaching shakespeare i
have
no idea why anyone who speaks english
would not want to study shakespeare but
uh i had a child
my eldest daughter spencer who is uh
an actress herself now but it was when
she was about three months old and i was
walking across the park with her wrapped
up in my
uh my sheer skin um overcoat
and looking down at her and i thought to
myself i better get a real job
i didn't mean i didn't mean like a
straight job i meant
an acting job that paid right and the
place to find one of those was
television
so i went to the place where i was
staying at the time with my old buddy
gregory brown we were sharing an
apartment
and uh i'm watching tv for the first
time in
you know my life practically and he said
what are you up to what's going on he
said i think uh
i think i just need to watch some
television he said you're gonna get a tv
job aren't you i said
i think so so
that's kind of what happened that's
right and so
again before we get to that too what was
robin williams like as a classmate
fantastic always the same guy always
always on i mean he was
you know constantly
doing material whether or not it was
practiced or not i doubt it was
he just had that thing he was just
always on
and always uh hysterical always funny
and and a motor mouth i mean just he
just kept talking
and if it wasn't funny at the moment it
would be any minute
so you know you just knew he was going
to get there
and uh an extraordinary guy
and i remember our very last meeting was
just on the red carpet at the golden
globes since the last time i saw him
and uh what was weird was i
i think that was the night i won an
award for uh
for um boss
who all of tom came and uh tom kane's
issue is that he had
um lewy body and of course later they
found out that that's what robin was
suffering with and uh
boy that is one obscure weird lonely
disease man
we picked it because it was so obscure
we thought you know
great sort of like you know the meters
running uh
device for the show boss that we were
doing and uh
it just seemed like a sort of painfully
ironic lesson
but uh he was one of the greats he
certainly was
no doubt about it we had you know bob
saget on as well
and he had a story about seeing him and
being around him
uh in the 70s at the comedy store and
how
it's just fascinating to hear who was in
your juilliard class and and you know
obviously where what paths you all took
we had a good had a great bite yeah
there was a ton of other actors i mean
uh franny conroy went on to do quite a
few things uh christine branch
you're ahead of me um they were just
wonderful wonderful kevin kevin um no
jesus don't forget his last name um
was in a couple classes ahead of me
david steyers was there
which was really great david stars by
the first day
um well the first couple of weeks i was
at school david steyers came to
visit and started to talk and we started
chatting a little bit
he said are you eating and i guess i
looked pretty skinny at the time
and uh i said well not really he said
i'm gonna buy you dinner
so he bought me dinner uh it was just
terrific because i was having a pretty
pretty
rough time at the time and uh his
kindness was always
uh very much appreciated and then
uh 20 years later he's a guest star on
frasier
well and also before that he was uh
winchester
on on so i'm wondering did did did
juilliard have a class on how to play
fastidious people who
occasionally came across as the smartest
person in the room who wrote people the
wrong way
very proud so
you got this phone call of cheers let's
talk about that one day your phone you
get a phone call who called you
who explained to you the the character
frasier crane what was that pitch to you
how did it all work out
for what obviously was such a big one
and gretchen used to work for
paramount at the gulf and western
building which is now the trump
tower not the one on fifth avenue but i
guess one of the first ones where it had
a
series of condos it was a hotel as well
so i walked up to that place and it was
the g w
building back then gulf and western and
went up to see
gretchen and she said i heard about you
from mandy potenkin
and i said oh really because we had done
sunday to park with george together
um a sondheim musical
and uh she said i had lunch with him
last week and he i asked him if he knew
any funny leading men
and he said yeah kelsey graham was a
pretty funny guy
so that's what brought me in and then
she explained to me what frasier was
and i thought well i could probably play
this guy she handed me some sides
some you know written out scenes and i
went home and sort of looked through him
and i went in the next day and i read
for her and then she said we're going to
put you on camera we're going to do a
camera test
and uh what did she call it it was
called a personality test
okay okay great so i went home that day
and i thought personality tests well
just let me see if i can play this guy i
think and i thought who is he's kind of
a preppy guy a little bit sort of
high proud maybe a little awkward so
i remembered that my mother had given me
some christian new york golf slacks that
were
bright yellow and i
thought i think that's this guy
well i dug him out of my old chest and
uh i realized oh
crap they haven't been hammed so
having learned to do a nice cross stitch
back when i was doing costumes at the
shakespeare festival
i got them out measured them did a
beautiful job having them
and then wore those in crisp and
beautiful with a black blazer and a
white shirt
and uh went on camera and that's when
jimmy burroughs basically said well
that's one of the funniest looking guys
i've ever seen
i've still never really been very
charmed by that statement or flattered
but
nonetheless it got their attention and
uh i flew out to california the next
couple of days
um red for a group of people and
they finally got me they got me a job
[Music]
[Applause]
do you own or rent your home of course
you do and i bet it can be hard work you
know what's easy
bundling policies with geico geico makes
it easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's
geico.com
[Applause]
what in the world was it like to be on
the set of cheers
when it was taking off and then
as iconic a television show as there's
ever been
yeah i love a wonderful bunch i mean
they caught lightning in the bottle i
guess i mean uh
casting wise they just nailed it with
everybody
and i was you know blessed to be invited
into that bunch
i mean they'd sort of written themselves
into a corner i suppose and they had to
break up sam and diane for a while and
so there was my opening and uh i was
lucky enough to be able to
you know get enough left that they
thought we should keep him around
because
obviously i wasn't going to stay with
diane um so that
it worked out really well and they were
you know jimmy's
you know arguably one of the brightest
guys in television certainly
and uh was so easy to get along with i
really really enjoyed him
and of course i didn't know he was a
burroughs kid at first and then somebody
said oh you know who he is he's hey
burroughs kidnapping hey girls used to
watch him out to tell the truth so
it's or what's my line it was one of the
other um but um i uh i just really hit
it off with jimmy
uh just you know we all just sort of
fell in love and and with ted and with
woody went out after uh
after nick colisanto died who played
coach
and uh ria same thing i still i mean
maria and i get her hair cut by the same
girl to this day
and so that's uh it's a big
big part of my life a big a good
beginning
in los angeles and it was nick colasanto
who said
after the first day of reading he said
to me walked up and said to me
you're good never forget you are born
with one set of fingerprints
i said thank you having
a few months later it kind of kicked
when i realized oh they're gonna they're
gonna do
things to you in this industry once you
kind of get on television a lot of stuff
starts to happen falling into place that
maybe is beyond your control in a funny
way and uh
you don't want to lose sight of who you
are so
i was born one set of fingerprints my
name is kelsey grammer and that's the
latest
day you know so it really helped out in
the end you know i thought
great go ahead no no i've never heard
that before but it is
actually something that works outside of
hollywood yeah
it's it's it's one of those pieces of
advice for life for every kid
everybody ever talking to them when
they're just starting out you spot
something in them
just remind them you know it's you got
you you got you
and that then don't don't mess with it
don't want something don't let anybody
take that away from you
that's the key he got one set of
fingerprints and that was a that wasn't
even a way homer you gotta like get
figured out
months you later
i mean what was it like when it when
when cheers what was it like when cheers
ended
kelsey was that oh right it was a great
experience now
of course i i was sober at that time
which was an interesting period of my
life but uh
uh the rumor was that as we were all in
boston with jay leno and stuff is that
everybody was blasted and blitzed but i
i don't think that was true i think
everybody was pretending to be blasted
in blitz because it was the end of
an era for every one of them and uh i
mean that was the first real big shot
that any of them had had
you know and they were all they were all
just
loved and adored by the people of boston
and by
by the television audience and uh i
think they all kind of knew that it was
a time that
should be celebrated should be
you know captured for life because it's
not going to happen again
you know i was i was pretty fortunate to
go on to something else and have that
work out but i mean that moment was
huge for a decade of our lives we all
lived in that light
and it was fantastic and the charles
brock who wrote it you know i mean
the guys were amazing right and it's
also rare though kelsey to
to continue to play the character
and have something entirely different
as well and be so monstrously successful
in its own right and um
did you have that lined up when cheers
was ending
or or what was the secret
in the eighth season of cheers the folks
at paramount came to me and said listen
when cheers is done we'd like you to do
a show
a little deal a production deal that
said that's what we would do once once
teddy basically said that he was done
and on the 11th season he said that's it
it's my last one this is it
so uh we started developing at that
point and started to meet with a few
writers and
have a few ideas and so once the show
ended
we got back to work and came up with a
script
for an idea about a guy who was kind of
a
a wall street mogul who had a motorcycle
accident because he was a bit of a wild
guy i think
i personally probably inspired that
um the president of paramount
invited me to dinner after we submitted
the script
john pike was his name is his name he's
still i still see him over at bellaire
country club
john uh sat me down after the first
cocktail and uh and some spaghetti
and said kelsey i think
a sitcom should be funny
so i said so you're not really in love
with this idea we have
he said no i think you should play
frasier
made some sense to me i mean built an
audience
um interesting guys certainly not
developed yet so we don't really know
who he is yet
uh the only thing i added then was i
thought well
let's get rid of wives and children
which is right
because if you've got a relationship
that was kind of a sour
relationship i didn't think it had much
i didn't think it had much comedy in it
we'd already had a breakup with love so
i thought well let's not let's not
hang on with that but the son i wanted
him to be a responsible
father but children on a television
sitcom
are the most interesting thing on the
show because they're growing up
change from month to month as you see
when you go away for three weeks for
your own kids you think oh my god look
what happened to them
so i think what happens is a show
is by default it has to revolve around
this growth
this growth that's taking place if it's
a young man who's cute
you know that becomes the story you know
whether or not he's in a boy band or
whatever you know
i'd rather do a show that's funny that
isn't centered around the kid
so i got a dog instead yeah
and you also i mean who came i'm
fascinated by this kelsey and i
and i i you know um i
this sort of stuff i i can't get enough
of and i think the listeners either
because you know was there any part of
you that thought
maybe i i shouldn't do that obviously
you you
you have won a tony award you have
won a golden globe for a completely
different role in boss
you know like you have done other things
but did you at any point in time think
to yourself
maybe i shouldn't do that
yeah it happens all yeah you do go
through that yeah why did you
why did you agree why did you ascend by
then i'd already had that conversation
with myself i had that one before i did
cheers
yeah so i said this could mean the end
of your career right so it was
okay but so 20 years later
the fraser was over so it's okay
well and i i i do want to get in a a in
a second to see if fraser is in fact
completely over but um so
so um who came up with the idea to make
uh frasier
a uh a talk show
host in seattle with a father who is
completely different
from him and a brother who's even more
right this is good peter casey was
really responsible for the father
element because he would he we sat down
and talked at one point he said you know
i've been really thinking about we're in
a generation now where a lot of our
parents are moving in with us
and i'm not sure if that was
particularly his case but
it was a phenomenon that had sort of
been happening around
our lives you know and in that time in
america and uh
we all agreed that that was probably a
pretty good idea and uh that was when i
remembered i said oh my god i love john
mahoney he'd be a great dad
and they all chimed in with that and
called him and
got him on uh got him on board we sent
him the first script and i mean the
great thing about the first group was
everybody
you know it was such a good script and
uh everybody that read it wanted to
be involved so that was a blessing but
then yeah then
then the brother uh was um a casting
person's idea they just said oh by the
way you know what if you're thinking of
having a brother for
kelsey grammer this guy david pierce
looks just like him so that's
how that was born and then
jane uh as daphne they thought somebody
needed to look after
martin because he you know had the hip
thing and needed to do the rehab
um we weren't exactly sure what what
that was going to lead to but they hired
they told me they'd hired a roller
interested to grow an english accent
i i was kind of against that because uh
nanny and the professor was still kind
of in the back of my head and i thought
oh i don't know if that's a good idea
but they said well come down and read
with her
so i i drove down the studio and uh
they said she's right in here i said
okay great i'll go read with her and
they were all following me and i said no
no no
i'll go read with her and i said okay
i'll close them to work and we sat down
we talked about five minutes
read through the scenes i went down and
said she's great let's do it
so that's that's where that one happened
and then uh
roz the character of roz was someone
that
they had known there was a gal that
worked in production uh
with them whose name was roz doyle and
it was sort of an homage to her
and she was a great level-headed you
know strong-willed woman
who was a little quirky and we couldn't
find the right actress for it
and um we originally cast
uh phoebe from friends
yeah because we weren't sure we weren't
sure if she was the right choice at the
time we just thought you know well she's
quirky and fun
so let's let's try that and about a week
in the rehearsal we said ah
damn it's just it's not landing so
we all knew who perry was she had done
it cheers before and we called her and
she read
we gave her the part and of course you
know the other actress went on to become
quite famous in a show called friends
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my sleep number bed i get my
sleep iq score every single morning just
to know exactly how well i slept
i set my side of the bed to the way i
want my firmness to be
and my wife does the same my sleep
number is 60. hers is 70. it's just 10
numbers apart
but it really does mean the world of
difference and getting proven quality
sleep from sleep number
means the world of difference as well
because a good night's rest helps boost
immunity increase
energy and quality sleep improves
recovery sleep helps us recover faster
from exercise
injuries and illnesses deep sleep
decreases anxiety overnight
by recognizing connections in the brain
rem sleep is essential for many of the
brain's cognitive and emotional function
since most of it happens during the
second half of the night so it's
important
to get seven to nine hours of sleep
discover proven quality sleep with sleep
number save one
thousand dollars on the new sleep number
360 special edition smart bed during the
memorial day sale
only at sleep number stores or sleep
number dot com slash eisen don't forget
the slash
eisen sleep number dot com slash eisen
is there more frasier to come
yes we're hashing that out right now now
what's great is we've so we've sort of
put a launching pad in place that we've
discussed with cbs and the guys at
paramount plus but we're going to end up
uh it involves everybody in the cast
some of the cast members
are probably you know are wisely a
little leery of that so we're
we're tweaking some of the script ideas
and
and coming up with another draft like a
polish to invite them in in a more
significant way so they understand that
you know oh okay this is where we're
headed as well
seeing as how we have what is the
groundwork for where fraser fraser's
gonna go next
uh which is a little bit like um
i mean the best thing i can say now is
he's a bit like george bailey
frazier you know it started out that way
he's got an idea of how his life is
supposed to go
and it never works that way so
he was going to end up in another
situation where he hadn't planned on it
and uh but of course ends up being the
richest man in the world
you know because he gets all these
relationships and this
wonderful wonderful set of challenges
every week so
that's what we're working on i think
it's going to be fine
and uh when do we expect it when do we
expect it
oh oh i expected i'm pretty confident
we'll shoot something by the beginning
of the year
and then it's kind of to them we can
turn a show around in about two weeks
but you know maybe you know they'll tell
time when they want to release it
is it still set in seattle as well is
that the idea or
no it's good to i think it's good to
pick up and leave for new beginnings and
so that's what we've done
all right well i'm i i can't wait for it
um
and before we get to your current
projects what's your favorite
simpsons episode how did you get
involved with them those are two
questions you can handle them however
you wish in whichever order
i had a tendency when i would show up at
work to uh sing
i always been saying i'm that's the way
i was it's kind of hairpin i am
so i used to walk into the set of cheers
often and sing
oh the good life
and everybody kind of get a giggle and
say oh that kelsey he's irrepressible
but uh sam simon used to be on the
writing staff of cheers
he went off and became extraordinarily
famous as one of the creators of the
simpsons
somewhere i guess the second season
maybe i i still don't really know where
it sits in the
in the chronology of the show uh
sam gives me a call and says we caught
with his character uh he's been in the
show already but he doesn't speak
now he's going to speak we're going to
find out who he's he's and we think you
should voice him
and can you sing a cole porter song
well you know i can oh it had sam said
sam said
are you still singing it's who i am
and uh so he said we do you know this
cole porter's song
every time we say goodbye and i said yes
i know that song and i can sing it
so off we went and we recorded the first
episode and
it takes about a year and a half at
least it did then for the show to go
from recorded
uh product to fully animated product so
about a year and a half later
i hear you know the show's been on and
it was pretty well received
and then a buddy of mine who was a
professor at evanston illinois
sends me a picture and he says
can you believe this it was the side of
a building
painted with a giant mural of
sideshow bob with the words underneath
saying
free sideshow bob oh
[Music]
it caught the imagination of any number
of really you know juvenile people
and stayed there forever
and what's your favorite sideshow bomb
episode or that would be the one where i
sing the songs you know when i sing um
uh hms metaphor i mean it is it has to
be that's the one with the rake
the rake is you know it's like my
greatest girlfriend do you have a
favorite line a favorite sideshow bob
line i do this isn't the one where
actually um
david pierce played my brother sister
bob's brother
uh cecil and
i'm saving lisa and bart at the time
and lisa says what are we going to do
blah blah blah blah and i say
well lisa you don't spend 15 years as a
homicidal maniac without learning a
thing or two about dynamite
[Music]
so that's my favorite line when that's
written in on the page you must say i
can make an
absolute five-course meal out of that
you're like you must have just been
doing mental cart wheels when you see a
written line like that for you
there's a certain lilt to it
a thing or two
[Music]
[Applause]
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by first leaf
who hasn't been there you're standing in
the wine aisle staring at the shelves do
you want a california red maybe one from
oregon something organic maybe just the
one with the really nice label do you
even know what's any good
maybe you need someone to help you maybe
you need that confidence to grab that
bottle
open it up and enjoy it thankfully
there's first leaf
a better way to discover wine at a
fraction of the price you'll find in a
store
firstleaf is a fully customizable wine
club that sends curated boxes of wine
that are perfect
for you and they have more award-winning
wine than anyone else with first leaf
this is important there's no guesswork
no misguided recommendations from an
employee who doesn't
know what you like and no frustration on
your part each wine shipment is entirely
customized
to your unique palette and preferences
unlike big box wine membership
first leaf uses a one-of-a-kind
algorithm and your feedback
to curate future wine recommendations
the more wines you taste and review
the better the shipments get first leaf
works directly with the world's
best wine makers not only to find the
best wines available but then to pass
the savings
on onto you saving you up to sixty
percent off
retail save time money and stress with
first leaf the wine club designed with
you in mind it is so awesome you put in
your preferences
and you get a one you like think about
that join today
and you'll get six bottles of wine for
29.95
and free shipping just go to
tryfirstleaf.com
eisen that's six bottles of wine for
29.95 and free shipping
try it at tryfirstleaf.com that's
tryfirstleaf.com
[Applause]
before i let you go kelsey talk about
your your current projects
um that are going to be uh front and
center for all of us
is the film that uh the space between
uh and the god committee what did you
like about this what are you
[Music]
two things um arguably because it's a
film you get to do something you haven't
done before that's that's
that's what i focus on i tend to you
know it depends sometimes there's a
little money in it sometimes there's not
so much that's that's fine
uh space between i just had to do
because it's just uh
it reminded me of half the guys i grew
up with with a particular friend of mine
named ray kennedy
who was a songwriter songwriter who
wrote some of the most famous songs
you've ever
heard so he has a pretty
long shadow himself but we were great
friends and
um he died a few years ago when this
part came on i thought well i can
dedicate a little
braid to this into this part or dedicate
this part to him a little bit
so it's inspired by by what i knew of
him my love for him he was a
great guy and this this character is
larger than life
and never quits never quits he's still
still trying to record music
he's been ostracized by the music
industry and he's a pretty
great rock and roller but from the 70s
and the film set in the 90s and it's a
tale of redemption
a tale of a guy who gets a chance to
sort of reclaim his life
and reclaim his love and it's uh it's
great
it's exciting i must say so myself well
no it's terrific and
it's uh gonna be uh right around the
corner uh on vod june 15th the god
committee
in theaters uh july fourth weekend right
committee is a not such a fun thing
to to spend time with uh although i want
people to
i want people to see it because it's an
important story and
it's really moving it's just
the guy dies don't want to give it away
it's about that group of people that
decides who receives
um organ transplants and it's
dubbed the god committee by somebody you
know a couple of decades back
and uh so that's what it really centers
on is their
fight to balance funding for research
with
the right uh recipient of a donor heart
or a donor liver or donor
kidney and uh and what the uh
sort of the slippery slope morally and
ethically
is involved in it and my guy is a
wonderful character to play there's not
a there's not a lot of light at the end
of the tunnel
but i'm pleased with the work and i
think it's an important piece so i was
glad to do that
i've got another one coming out a few
months after this so it's it's been
it was an interesting year with the
coven
sort of event that took place because
everything just sort of
was abrupted you know it just stopped
so all these films might have come out a
different time but in a way in a weird
way it's kind of fun now because i'm
i'm displaying a sort of a
uh ease with you know different
characters whatever that uh that
people might not have expected and right
charming the hearts of men
is a new film coming out in august and
then uh one of your emmys
for troll hunters guillermo de tour
del toro's uh award-winning animated
series troll hunters and
you got a film version coming up
yeah amazing that's a terrific piece
that's terrific my grandson fell in love
with that i got a
10 year old grandson now emmitt and uh
he i sent him all the miniature stuff
all the merchandising he's got it all he
loves that
sword but it's terrific i've watched
some of it and i um
even i got excited watching it so i'd
say
[Laughter]
well i i got to tell you kelsey and um
you know i could literally go
on and on and on do you ever sit back at
any point in time
and you may not have time because uh
you've got
little ones running around and your
hands full being a father grandfather
uh family man actor
i mean my gosh just some of the names
that we've
uh heard during this pod who you've
you know called colleagues or classmates
and
cheers frasier simpsons
i mean this is some all-time
mount rushmore like you could literally
ask somebody come up with a mount
rushmore of shows and
the ones that i mentioned arguably could
be on there
do you ever sit back and wonder about
your journey
uh at all kelsey um these are great
questions rich
um thank you by saying how much i admire
you i've been
a big fan for quite a while thank you um
i look back at a lot of
the traffic of my life and i am so
thankful for it
um there are there have been some real
challenges and some difficult days
but there were so many wonderful days
and i'm
really blessed to have found
that thing in me that's me and that's an
actor
it's just this guy who likes to act who
sings a bit
who act and uh thankfully i found a
career
and a group of people that said you know
what we're gonna make sure you live
pretty well
because you do it really well and that's
i don't know i couldn't be more thankful
i'm really gonna be more grateful for
what i ended up with and uh
uh the fight's not over and i'm still
you know of course
you know it's never i'm never gonna fit
but uh
i i was seeing this morning i was
thinking uh
pieces of a new musical for some stuff
we're working on and
i had that moment as i was singing the
song where i just thought
i could be you know 15 again just
just that boy who found his voice
and gets to use it
it's a good thing it certainly is and
i'm assuming sam simon asking you back
in the day
do you still sing frasier had not come
out yet because we all know how those
credits ended for all those
yeah that's right tell me tell me at
least you're going to do that again
right are you going to reboot that song
through the
closing credits actually segue from that
song to another
we'll see yeah kelsey grammer thank you
sir
greatly appreciate you being on this
episode of just getting started
[Music]
how great was that that was nothing
short of to use a frasier crane term
delightful with kelsey grammer i truly
could have gone
on and on and on uh with him and
um i i think the line to come out of
this part as you know i like to
choose something from what the guest
just said to wrap things up and
and leave everyone with a thought or
random or
something that i think um should stand
the test
and i think how about this a line from
coach from cheers the actor nicholas
colasanto
telling him don't forget you you have
only one fingerprint
and uh that you or you and don't let
anybody ever take that away from you or
at least that was
kelsey's interpretation of it
certainly since he
you know in in a business where
people believe you should be one thing
you think you should be another and
i think acting is just one endeavor in
which
of many in which that's the case i i i
kind of dig that
as you know over the you know um
[Music]
first dozen or so episodes of this show
uh that's what the show's about is
a conversation with somebody to leave
you
with something portable about how to go
about your life
maybe you learned something about one of
your favorite shows one of your favorite
comedians one of your favorite
movies along the way
and um i i kind of
i kind of dig that line and i wouldn't
think that the guy from
uh cheers coach would be the one to give
me that
that's another thing about the world
that
it's um it's what uh it's from a person
you least expect
anybody could give you a piece of advice
and obviously the actor
just did a great job playing somebody
who is really flighty
and maybe had a little bit missing
upstairs
but um that's that
you've got one life one fingerprint
your only fingerprint it's yours
nobody can have it you do with it what
you need to do with it but you also
need to take the opportunities that come
your way and believe in yourself believe
in that fingerprint
i love it i'm gonna take that i'm gonna
use it
and hopefully you will too that'll wrap
it up for this edition of just getting
started if you missed the
previous episodes with rob lowe and jake
tapper
and bill burr dr anthony fauci matthew
mcconaughey was our first
if you missed any of them they're right
there on our library please
share it with as many people as you'd
like tell them to
download us give us the old five-star
rating wherever you get
your podcast as well um and be sure to
also check out my daily show the rich
eisen show you can get it
where all podcasts are acquired both are
from the cumulus podcast network so this
is rich eisen on this episode of just
getting started signing off
you